عمل كعميل المزدوج للالماني والغرب
مع الالمان وغداهم بمعلومات وهميه لم تكن
سببا في خساره الحرب العالميه الثانيه
وتحرير اوروبا الغربيه فحسب بل وفي نهايه
الراي
وبسبب مواهبه في التمثيل والكذب
عام
1912 لعائله سياسيه الليبراليه وعمل
بوظائف عده حتى بدايه سن الرشد ثم تولى
اداره مزرعه دواجن صغيره في عام
1936 وهو ما تزامنا مع الحرب بين
الجمهوريين الفاشليين والقوميين الشيوعيين
اليساريين
شارك بس يا علي مدد بالحرب الاهليه في
بلاده دون ان يطلق رصاصه واحده رغم ان كلا
الجانبين اساء معاملاته فالجمهوريون
احتجزوا عائلته كراهائم
واتهموهم بمعاده الثوره فيما سجنه اليسار
المتطرف عندما تحدث ضد ميولهم عندما انتهت
الحرب انتقل غارسيا لمدريد حيث اسس فندقا
صغيرا ظل يعمل فيه الى اندلعت الحرب
العالميه الثانيه وحينها وجد الفرصه
لينتقم من النازيين والشيوعيين معا فعرض
خدماته للعمل على الاستخبارات البريطانيه
لكنها رفضت فتواصل مع المخابرات الالمانيه
واقناعهم بانه نازي متعصب وبانه مسؤول
حكومي
سيتم ارساله بمهمه الرسميه الى لندن
فقابله الالمان بعد تردد كبير واخضعوه
لتدري على التجسس ثم طلبوا منه تجميع شبكه
من العملاء هنا
خدع غارسيا الالمان وبدل من السفر لندن
انتقل الى لشبونه وانشى شبكه من الوكلاء
الوهميين وبدا بارسال الرسائل التي ظن
الالمان وانها تاتي من لندن بعد عامين من
العمل الخفي اكتشفه البريطانيون فاعجب به
وقابلوه للعمل كعميل مزدوج ثم نقلوه الى
لندن حيث من حسن جاربو وهناك توحد الجهوده
مع عميل اخر هو توماس هاريسس ليبتكر
الاثنين مالا يقل عن 27 وكيلا فرعيه لكل
منهم قصص حياه كامله ومن هناك تابعه ارسال
رسائل غالبيتها وهمي
بحلول عام
1944 كانت القوه البريطانيه والامريكيه
تخطط لغزو اوروبا الغربيه على شواطئ
نورماندي الفرنسيه وهو الغزو الذي حمل
الاسم الرمزي عمليه افرلورد او دي داي انا
ذاك اعتقد هتلر ان الغزوه سيكون لممر
كاليه وليس لمعبر نورماندي فحصنا الالمان
تلك المنطقه اكثر بكثير من نورمان فيما
حرس غارسيه على ارسال المعلومه الدقيقه
لموقع الغزو لكنه اخرها لتصل بعد بدء
الغزو الفعليه فخسر الالمان الموقع وكان
انزال نورماندي بمثابه بدايه تحرير اوروبا
الغربيه وشكلت خدمه غارسيا مساهمه كبيره
في نجاحها فوصف بانه اعظم عميل مزدوج في
الحرب العالميه الثانيه قدم غارسيا ما لا
يقل عن 62 تقريبا
طالع منها على ما يقرب من المليون دولار
كما منع صليبا حديديا لخدمته من هتلر ونال
عضويه وسام الامبراطوريه البريطانيه ما
جعله الرجل الوحيد الذي تكرم من الجانبين
بالحرب العالميه الثانيه بعد نهايه خدمته
نقلته المخابرات البريطانيه الى كركات
فعاش في فنزويلا مع اسرته قبل وفاته في
عام
وبقيت سيرته سرا لولا ان كشف عنها في
مذكراته التي حملت اسم عمليه تجربه